they said they saw some fall from the
sky they checked their backyard and they
saw something with uh like eight to nine
feet no clothes green green colored men
uh not human with uh like the eyes were
glowing and they did not it was not a
human being
did you see it did you see it yeah me
and his side what'd you see
it was like a
it was like a big creature a big
creature yeah because I'm not going to
BS you guys one of my partners said they
saw some fall out of this guy too so
that's why I'm kind of curious did you
see anything land in your backyard or
I see a cat over there
do you have cameras
[Music]
did you see it no
I'm kind of curious now I wanna I wanna
know if there's aliens
where did you where did they go
well they say that I'm gonna show you
have a dirt backyard can you show me if
there's a
and I'm sorry did you see them go
anywhere
no you didn't do something did they
probably go that way
[Music]
hey did you guys
hey this might sound like a really dumb
question but did you guys see anything
fall out of the sky
yeah we got a call and one of my
partners actually said that they saw it
too
so if you happen to see any uh like I'm
not bsing you if you see anything no
like if you see any like little well not
little in this case
um
they're claiming uh eight to nine foot
tall green beans that were in their
backyard sounds crazy but you never know
uh your neighbors your fine neighbors
over here but again I would normally
discount it as probably not real right
here yes uh I would normally discounted
as nothing however
um
seen as one of my partners said they saw
it too only reason I'm actually
investigating any further so if you guys
see anything especially in your backyard
please call 9-1-1 we'll come over okay
we just it might and we're hoping that
it's maybe just some kids pranking or
doing something stupid
they said they saw some fall from this
guy they checked their backyard and they
saw something with uh like eight to nine
feet no clothes green green colored men
uh not human with uh like the eyes were
glowing and they did not it was not a
human being so
yeah uh
what's up
yeah there's multiple people in this
home so we already checked huh
uh more than one
so if you see anything just uh give us a
call okay hope you have a good night
take care
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
did you guys have I'm sorry no
surveillance no video
that's when the company
I'm supposed
the landlord got a camera on the post
here over here
okay
see I said well the whole ATL area we'll
be around here for the night I'm going
to the hotel man
yeah I don't blame you
all right man ready
I wanted to find some aliens
well hey if those nine foot beings come
back into your backyard you call the
police and we'll come back here
don't call us all right
I ain't dealing with that
all right take care guys have a good one
okay all right let's just regroup over
here okay
[Music]
Marshall
Marshall's like no way okay yeah
I don't know uh
before that after that yeah we're on a
call by the Target right down there and
the Vons and she saw what she thought
was a shooting star fly in the sky she
saw something I believe in these things
I don't believe but Mom
I believe stuff I don't know but
listening listening to their stories
like I'm back there with like chills on
my arms like it's creepy you guys got it
too
it's weird bro why am I the only one
who's like okay it's weird it's just the
fact that our partner saw something at
the same exact time
the neighbors are still going around
looking so
yeah did you guys have I'm sorry no
surveillance no video
on the post here over here I'll show you
yeah the landlord has it so they don't
have access to it but someone else has
access to it
so yeah I said well the old HL area and
we'll be around here for the night so go
to the hotel man yeah I don't blame you
all right man we appreciate you calling
give us a call if you see anything else
okay
I know legit bro
no hey it does if those mindful beans
come back don't call us all right deal
with it yourself that I ain't dealing
with that
I'll try buying wave at you guys you're
on your own bro
[Music]
thank you